we back in the midwest teaching
gym he was like it ain't how fast it's
slow and steady that wins the race and I
never forgot
it it really is
crazy that you see him come and [__]
go in this town like you just see him
come and go in this town and for dice to
tell you that type of story that's
little steps and he's absolutely right
yeah I sat here and got pissed on and
watch people do what the [__] they
wanted yeah and I would and I'd see
other people that were [__] animals
and nobody looked at these people and
then the card
flips but then at times
uh a few of them slip through the cracks
yeah and you look at them and you wish
them well but you know somewhere along
the line they're going to crack cuz this
is tough and it's like Ronda Rousey when
they all come at you yep there no
shortcuts they all come at you for the
same [__] Direction the show is
brought to you by on it for all your
supplements go to honor.com right now
and press in church and get 10% off your
order delivered to your house this show
and it's an honor to have these guys on
the podcast hello tushi.com B days are
back [__] the church what's happening
now would love for you to have a bed to
keep your muffler clean and your nut
sack or monkey always intact do me a
favor go to hellotushy.com right now and
get 10% off your order go to hello
tushi.com
SL what
churchurch and uh that gets you 10% off
but hello tushi go look at and all look
at the fine line of bed they have and
how a bed is going to change your life
also I like to introduce one of my
favorites ceso they got my special on
there they got big Jay's on there they
got Nick Theo on there listen for all
your comedy go to see seo.com right now
and sign up one month free with promo
code Joey at checkout that seo.com
spelled
seo.com promo code Joey all right you
ready for the punchline here it is
seo.com
promo code
Joey oh
[__] Monday April 3rd got to pay back
April fools could suck your dick it's
over uh yeah give it to me H what church
what's happening now I'm
mad got to get back oh I need some get
oh [__] this is what you need baby boy
pay
back pay
back pay it
back here you go [__] up this
what church what's happening
now little lead AKA
festos my man Steve V Simone AKA Steve
Simone you got Uncle Joey Diaz coming at
you [__]
what damn to me
[Music]
what's happening you bad [__]
it's another edition of the church
welcome to podcastville I got my main
man Steve Simone lisad with his blue
shirt on I gave him a
bong his eyeballs almost blew out was
that the same thing you gave Dean Del
cuz that's what I felt like no that was
whatever the [__] this is the devil's La
when I gave you the same [__] I gave you
last week and your face got all red and
[__] like that I want to thank all the
people came to the shows at nyak one of
the funnest [__] weekends I've had in
a long time uh a lot of crazy people
showed up uh my man Andrew nandal showed
up my other dog showed up with spaghetti
sauce I traveled all the way back with a
jar of [__] spaghetti sauce uh you
know the [__] troop showed out and it
all ended with some guy getting hit in
the head with a bottle in the [__]
bathroom on Saturday night and telling
me it was the best night of his [__]
life CU it was his birthday and he came
to the show so I want to thank everybody
who came out I had a great time to do
with the tattoos from the Bronx I mean
there was just the two Italian dudes the
dula Brothers [__] Fidel and his
brother Raul the Jews who came I mean
you know I loved everyone I had every I
had a great time last weekend the
[__] food was great I had spaghetti
and clam sauce I got to be honest with
you I even had the sushi twice wow
delicious you know me you can't eat
[__] meat on Friday so you got to
slip in some Philly rolls and [__] and a
shrimp temporal roll to get the party
started and I've been holding out good
it was it's been a good length me too
this has been a very good length I stuck
to my Fridays I didn't eat no [__]
Edibles it's been good for you I was
going to say for me it's been like a
like the opposite of listen for you it's
every day at the office this is it we
don't stop here Lisa this is what makes
our podcast different than everybody
else we don't stop the party here what
do you mean podcast I was going to tweet
something this is a lifestyle the church
what's happening now is a mental
lifestyle if you ain't running with the
Hebrews we got many different directions
and philosophies coming into the
church you know what I'm saying yeah I
know you but I I woke up like I I I
always try to think about like what
other people going through it offices I
got two emails from Joey at about 1:45
a.m. last night and they both started
with I've been up since I've been up
since 1:00 a.m. [__] sucker you're
slipping we're taking over 2,000 like
it's just like what kind of email like
this email would go to HR like this
would be a big scandal at a d last night
I laid down I [__] sat there with my
wife my friend Becky came over we had
Donuts we watched Angel Hart with Mickey
roor phenomenal [__] movie The Nero
stole it again as the devil [__]
tremendous when he eats that egg he
scares the [__] out and and my man Dave
Foley put it up in his [__] website
so it's an HD like that new [__] oh my
God but anyway and it's funny my
daughter came in a and I'm watching
whatever she goes daddy it looks like a
scary movie I go I know I'm scared
myself why you sit next to me and we
could be scared together she just looked
at me and ran out of there that's a
scary ass movie just to look at the the
darkness of that movie you know when
that movie came out it was that Golden
Child oh yeah and something else came
out in 1987 and New York Times wrote a
big article that the devil was alive and
kicking that year that that was the year
of the devil in cinema wow because those
three movies really [__] they really
hit hard like The Golden Child nobody's
ever watched that was Eddie Murphy
that's Eddie Murphy nobody sees that
movie Nobody Knows It exists nobody ever
paid attention to it's it's like after
48 hours in trading places and I think
it's a little before coming back to
America right so he had done I don't
know if he did that black you know so
nobody's ever really seen Golden Child
Golden Child an interesting movie about
a kid who's going to save the world and
the chick posed in Playboy big tits she
was a little Indian girl
nice that's a weird movie no but it's
that's that whole year they said 1987
was the year of the devil there was one
other movie that came out in ' 87 that
was a strong devil flick I don't know
what the name of it is it really doesn't
matter but right I uh my wife went to
bed Becky left and it was 11:15 I go let
me to go lay down I'm tired like I was
physically and mentally tired the
weekend in nyak you know the long flight
uh Jet Blue has won me over okay won me
over like it beats virgin it beats
American it beats Delta in those 6-h
hour trips they've been ahead of the
game for years I love I've L Jeet blue
they were the one of the first to have
TVs the seats are comfortable every and
you know what I love and I've only done
it a couple times those extra legum are
are great are great great everything on
there and you can get up get your own
potato chips sodas that's great well
because the D this was an old
date my agent called him and said can we
negotiate a price or something a little
higher he's selling more tickets now and
they came to an agreement I got just
tell him to get me a mint plane ticket
on let's just go down the middle if we
get the percentage just get me a mint
plane ticket I'll pay for it and send
them the receipt boom and they can pay
me there boom and that's what I did oh
that's great and it's a third of the
price of all those other big passenger
Airlines cuz Kennedy LAX to Kennedy is
three grand oh God I usually use
upgrades I get upgrades I have like 97
upgrades
so it's four to New York but you're not
going to guarantee that's what
everybody's scam is right what weird
thing happened was I went to bed in
these acidic when I got on to the
[__] flight in New York I get in the
flight in New York I'm I'm first on the
flight some chick with a dog is sitting
in the cubicle next to me cuz you got to
get an even number and you have the
cubicle to yourself okay so it's like
your own little apartment like a doctor
you should have seen me I fit in there
and I was sleeping like this like a baby
and the embryo I had [__] I had
Godfather 2 on they got rocky so good I
got Godfather 2 on the way there and I
got what I got on the way back maybe
Rocky Rocky W maybe Rocky was something
else I watched I watched a couple Law
and Orders I watched a couple shows
about the alligator people Swamp People
best show on television those rednecks
last week the guy's finger got cut off
he's still driving the thing he's like I
gotta rush to an ambulance cuz bacteria
might come in here but I still got to
make a living and go get myself an
alligator and he went with his little
fingerless [__] hand oh my God and at
the end of the show the guy goes man
that was a good job today he goes I give
you a high five but it's really a high
three [__] hysterical swamp people
that show on television so
uh when I woke up my cubicle smelt like
[__] farts like ass but these cic
Jews sat behind me and they went with
the whole Garb him and her had the whole
Garb when they came up then he making a
commotion he had to put some type of Jew
pajamas on this guy goes into the
bathroom and changes his little yamama
suit on to this other gray plaid pajama
suit on and his wife got up and she goes
in the bathroom and she changes into
some little Jewish outfit and she comes
down and sits down behind me I don't say
two words I was going to call E but it
was too early in the morning to bother
so I just went back to bed when I got up
dog it smelt like 22,000 farts in that
[__] cubicle I had a protein shake
and then I ate something on the there
was no [__] there wasn't a place
opening Kennedy that's how early I flew
out of there I flew out at 5:45 playing
boards at 5:15 there's nothing open do
you understand me yeah that's the worst
so I got on the plane I had like yogurt
granola I had the shrimp I had two
pieces of chicken and [__] waffles I
bent over and went to bed 3 hours later
I wake up with 20 minutes left my whole
cubicle smells like a dead fart even
with the fan going I'm thinking it's me
but it was so
I look around I look behind me the Jews
were gone you understand me they said
[__] it so I must have been fting the
whole [__] flight
tremendous when we landed I go what
happened to the Jews I didn't ask the
lady cuz I didn't want to be you you
made them move their first class scenes
those oh in the airplane farts must
especially yogurt and protein Shak oh
plus the salmon I had the day oh yeah
I'm killing the Philly rooll the clams
from Friday the clams from Friday that
Nayak water it was all over but the
shouting dog plus I had an espresso
before I went to sleep to have espresso
on there I got a double espresso and
then you went to sleep you know me dog
I'm I can do an a ball and close my eyes
I don't give a [__] anymore I remember
one time I was shooting a shitty movie
and I had stayed up snorting the whole
night and I went to the [__] thing
and I drank two red bulls and went right
to sleep I'll never forget that people
like man we've never seen that before
listen let me tell you a little secret
I've been snorting blow for 24 years two
red bulls could do anything to I'm down
to put sucking orange peels when you get
coked up in the old days I had a
Colombian friend who would say to take
the orange cut it and suck on the orange
peel like halftime at a soccer game yeah
suck the orange peel and whatever
vitamin is in the peel will neutralize
the acid and the cocaine I I I did it
once or twice who the [__] knows even
when you laid on your heart's beating to
Death Steve D Simone and myself will be
at the the borada July 29th are you
kidding me or what we're trying to pick
up a gig in Delaware on the 28th just so
we can swing by and get cookies and the
cheese steak you know what I'm saying
listen we're going to go to Delaware
let's stop no we can't Joey it's only 3
hours listen we're going to stop for
[__] it's right there we'll go to
termines we'll get the cookies we'll
swing by John's to get a sandwich what's
going on in your world T you're making
pizzas now making homemade pizzas I had
some uh one of the families from
Children's Hospital over yesterday so it
was a great day you're becoming like an
old Italian that's exactly it I was
listening to Dean Martin and making
pizza on a su next you know you're going
to get a little money going to buy a
house I go over your house you'll have
the [__] boots on you'll be out there
with the hose with plant tomatoes in the
backy that's all I want out of life how
crazy is that that you would become a
little Italian man like every
neighborhood has that Italian man
yep man that's crazy yeah cleaning the
driveway with the
hose you shrink an inch and a half
exactly every year like Mr Luna you were
bigger last year weren you nah kid
you're getting taller yourself nah Mr
Luna no no no no no you're shrinking
something's not right is Mr Luna a real
guy no no no I'm just think I'm just
thinking about all the Italian when I
was a kid before the new Moon Chinese
restaurant moved to 29th Street in Berg
Line Avenue across from my mom's bar
there was a very old
Italian delicatess and the other word
there's another word for it not Del
buter no it's an Italian and they call
it something and my earliest memories
was I would torment my mom till she
walked me across the street when you
walked on the right hand side they had
the counter with the cold cuts and the
cheese hanging and it smelled really bad
yeah but the vegetables were all there
in baskets on both sides and the little
candies and stuff but in the back they
had the boxes of the little candies yeah
that you just shove your hand the thing
is the one guy look like clemenza the
one brother was built just like Len's a
round head I could still see him now I
was three four years old bro I could
still see these guys and his brother was
an Italian who looked like you and they
both work together and every time I go
on in my mother they would make
sandwiches I'm I'm a big Morella guy I
love it because of that place I still
remember them handing me the Mortadella
and they give you the sample they give
you the oh the greatest and I used to my
mom would get Cuban crackers and you put
mult multi Mortadella and Cuban crackers
with that cheese that comes in the red
container GDA oh yeah not the smoked
goua but the regular gou you put that on
a Cuban cracker are you [__] kidding
me or what it doesn't get better and
after my mom died I didn't really eat
that Cuban food anymore and then one
night I went to Union City in ' 85 the
night before I left New Jersey to go to
Colorado I'll never forget I went down
there and my friend's Uncle ran the bar
and he asked me if I was hungry and I go
yeah and he gave me more the Dollar on
crackers they were he was Irish wow you
know and I was like God damn that's a
little bit of a sign though yeah that
was a sign I still my wife gets
Mortadella and I get pissed the [__] off
she'll get monadella once a month
they'll be in the refrigerator and I'll
see it and try to avoid it but I have a
few [__] toes of the reefa and I'm
just given call your name listen at this
point I'll eat like three pieces of
Madela with three saltine crackers
delicious just regular [__] Rich c
not not rich rich sucks with what the D
simple simple simp the best for
everything but that's what I remember
about those Italian Guys they were short
like I still remember I don't remember
the name of the deli and that all up the
corner was Ponty corvo's could it have
been gastronomia I don't know how to
pronounce them I'm sorry something what
saying Gastonia or something yeah they
they had a different name for it was
like a it's something because they sell
something it makes them it's not
liquor but when I would go to Christy
Lorenzo's house in the Summers he lived
in uh close to marbor I would exit 17
off the parkway there and when you come
up to that busy street
3435 there was one of those places a
Tratoria oh yeah one of those places and
they hung cheeses in there it was to me
it's a [__] Deli but they got the the
pepper stuff with Morad Del
cheese Pudo Shooters the Pudo Shooters
and all that [__] yeah yeah yeah would
you guys ever live in the Italian like
Italian section I've lived in the
Italian I lived there for 2 years and
it's still I still miss I would I would
move back there nor oh my God it
was it's just it was just so much so
much nicer so much and and I get the the
uh the benefit of having a house and
wanting to not have neighbors yep but
for me if like if just thinking about
you I can see you thriving in like just
any Italian neighborhood I just feel
like you like own the neighborhood be
like high-fiving love all the old people
that sit down you have a coffee with
them they tell you a story I love that I
love the food like North End I stopped I
remember getting a coffee there and some
guy lived in a neighborhood for like 50
years he was 80 years old he was
fantastic just he opened the Vault
started telling stories oh yeah every
restaurant was great I love
neighborhoods like that you know I was
telling my wife the other day I would
love to
find like my brother Joe cach I was
friends with this dude in Boulder he was
a baker on Monday nights and when I
first got comedy I would perform on
Tuesdays so Monday nights he was a b he
was a cooked Chef during the week but
Monday nights he was in charge of all
the desserts he would cover for somebody
okay so I'd go there about 1100 and meet
him and all his mistakes I I'd taste
everything all night but I would sit
there all night writing jokes and one
day he came to me goes you know what man
I'm I'm going to move back to [__] uh
Mississippi and he went down he opened
up a bagel shop they never saw a bagel
shop a bagel Miss is hit me yeah did he
do all right with it or just they didn't
know it's a [__] world he ended up
buying 17 houses the bagels shop grew he
just recently sold it wow because it was
enough he did 20 years 5 4 in the
morning making Bagels training people in
college town that's great I think it's
Mississippi State I think I'm not sure
don't quote me on that but that's the
thing to bring a culinary to a place
where nobody has it you know exactly
what you want listen I want four tables
with four people I the most I want my
restaurant is 16 people Y and I'm going
to put a table on the back just in case
if wee comes to town so you can sit next
to the cooks and sample of food and
that's it and it's very simple you're
not looking to be once you know what you
really want it makes life so much
simpler I'm walking into these
businesses lately and I'm no
mathematician but I got to sit there and
go how much money does it cost to keep
this restaurant alive yeah the overhead
costs the overhead cost and half these
places the square footage and half these
cities you know I was in New York last
week you know and I walked back from
Jimmy Norton and uh whatever show I want
to thank him for putting me on this show
Sam Roberts show and I always take a
little walk and I look at these places
and I go how many [__] grilled cheese
sandwiches do you have to sell do you
have to sell to [__] you know I went
to a deli that I always go to when I do
gym Norton I love it 50 yard walk down
the corner ham taay leg with some
roasted peppers on a kaiser roll with an
Orangina are you [__] kidding me with
the emphasis on Orangina you follow me
if you with me you know and then on the
way out you stop in there again and you
get an egg salad sandwich or a [__]
tur uh chicken salad sandwich tomato
come on dog on a kaiser roll and you get
in the cab and it drives you over to the
[__] Ferry and on the way there you
blast the [__] chicken oh dog I pay
the nine bucks I go over the [__]
Ferry but I'm sitting there going you
know I have a dream for a restaurant but
before I could open up my dream every
month I'm 30 G's in the hole because of
my
location and it's got to be for 30 GS
they got to have parking yep they got to
have a lot of things on top of that I'm
going have to have payroll so I'm minus
37,000 and that's I don't even know I'm
just throwing numbers up there I know I
know that it's expensive to rent such a
because I have friends that have
Jiu-Jitsu schools and they tell me what
the number is and I [__] [__] my
pants it's crazy that's that's always
something that blows my mind like when
like whenever I drive by like a copy
store or like a b a bagel is a little
bit you have can have good and bad
Bagels but businesses that don't really
have any like room for being a better
business I don't like it blows my mind
that people actually go and start like
it seems like there's too much
competition like if you have if you have
something you're talented at go for but
just just to open up another liquor
store is like jeez okay if you go down
to hunger right here and before you hit
Magnolia there a little coffee shop two
doors down from the
church if they're lucky mhm they sell 10
coffees a [__]
day yeah how they because how many how
many people could actually walk and get
coffee you know what they they hustle
I've been watching that cuz that's my
that's my stupidity MH in life when
somebody opens like okay a couple months
ago a wing and Curry Place opened on on
[__] B and whatever I was excited cuz
they had a sign that said Wings coming
soon okay I go Le Lee and I don't have a
place to go sit and chitchat you know
it's around the corner from the office
yeah but then the sign came up and it
was like wings but Curry I called Lee
right away like I'll never walk in there
how do you combine it's horrible foot
traffic it's a horrible combination this
is what I look at as an Ecom major I
know it sounds stupid to a lot of people
I like to see the rise and the rise of a
business and then if it falls I want to
know why why and you put together
together that it was a bad location and
there's just there's just a stupid
personal hobby of mine some people think
about the world being flat others think
about whatever this is what I think
about yeah you look at that coffee
shop and he got information about it's
been there for two years I've been
walking with Mercy she's four I stopped
in there many a time and got a coffee
with my wife coffee was good they're
Spanish they're very decent people they
had a child he's in there Mom and Pop so
that's but if you notice they're
building a hotel right next to it is
that a hotel that's a hotel so that
[__] them that that was it was looking
good it slowed down a little bit but
right now they're putting all this North
Hollywood Drive around that's it oh the
rent around going the rent is going
through the roof this is the hottest
neighbor building up over here but let's
pretend Lee had a good thing he sees a
coffee shop he sees that it's small and
he sees that there's no growth potential
in the business okay when you open up
any type of food industry indry you're
already in like a 30% range of failure
and I think that's speaking moderately
I'm no restaurant type of guy I think
that
sometimes people go somewhere and they
eat this I had a meal in India and I
think I'm going to bring the chef over
and open up the say you know and it just
and with restaurants it's like a a a
glamour thing like the critics have to
like it it's got to become a hot spot
like eat you know we go for breakfast
from time to time my wife we go to
either Denny's or eat mhm we always mix
it up
so you look at these places you know
whatever to grow well maybe I want to be
the best product I want to be and give
people I know how big I want to be this
guy had a vision when he opened up the
business he knew he didn't want to
expand he's he probably worked as an
engineer for 20 years right all right he
saw the corporate side of life he put
away some money and one day he said
guess what I'm going to do I live on 222
Smith Avenue I'm GNA [__] open up a
coffee shop on 52 Smith Avenue y I don't
give a [__] what anybody says get why I
tell you why cuz I'm going to be in
there all day gives me a chance to do
something with my life I still get a
pension and I get away from my wife for
eight [__] hours and I get to create
whatever the [__] I want coffee and if
people come in they come in if not I
don't really lose money I need to sell
two coffees a day and I break even y but
at least I'm doing something with my
life you following me Le some people
know exactly what they want you know
some people just open up a [__] place
you know nobody would dream of it's
amazing the places that you see open up
and you go that's not going to work and
you try to be positive you already know
by the name or the gimmick yep it
sounded like a good
idea but it's tough to sell cupcakes
that's a lot of cupcakes to pay rent and
there's certain locations that are just
the kiss of death no matter what they
put in there it just doesn't work or the
parking so
ass with the red light and you never
know till you're in it yeah it's true
like you never know till you're in the
[__] game but didn't you guys have in
the town when I grew up there was a one
spot that was a new restaurant every
eight months yep every eight months and
it was like I'm surprised like the the
real estate agents must just be lying to
people I just don't like it's weird how
that happens it's like a pregnant woman
it's like a woman that's G to get
married she sees what she wants to see
yeah it's like when you shoot a movie
and while you're shooting a movie you
think this is an Oscar winner and after
you watch it and the smoke settles and
The Ether goes away you're like o what
was I thinking you know how many times
have people come up to you didn't we
have somebody come in here once and say
I got a new show I've been in the
business for 20 years and this is the
best new show Le you remember he goes
this is the best new show that I worked
on and 3 weeks later the show was
cancelled was he lying to us no he fell
he believed it at that time he believed
The Ether while he was there the
shooting sometimes people believe their
own ether yeah they want it so bad that
they don't see the reality they don't
see the reality like I knew two guys
that opened up it was honestly the best
pizza I've ever had in Los Angeles but
their location was garbage there were
zero parking zero parking it didn't last
it couldn't last listen the best pizza
in Hollywood is at vetos yeah I agree on
Le you know what the chance of you
getting parking there zero to n zero to
n I love to take El and go to vetos and
get a slice and but you're not gonna get
parking it you gotta go to 11 o'clock in
the morning what what about uh up here
skinny kitchen they just they they
literally just expanded and within 6
months they closed up here and I'm
pretty sure the West Hollywood one is
closed I I I it's it it's crazy you know
but skinny kitchen sounds great on paper
yeah came in here and said it was
healthy option until he told me what
they had right and that's the that's the
[__] problem you know there's a place
called lemonade yes my wife [__]
hates it my wife thinks it's total
garbage I don't know I've never been I
love lemonade I see Lemonade all kinds
of salads and stuff like that right
Becky loves it everybody has different
opinions you know what I'm saying you
look at those
places and you say to yourself how the
how the [__] did I just pay $15 for a
salad that's everything in the city but
you don't know till you get home that
night and go wait a second I paid $15
for a bow lettuce and two pieces of
chicken you know how many salads you
could get how big is a bag of lettuce
bags of lettuce 10 of them how much are
those bags probably two bucks four bucks
and and two chicken cutet but you're
paying these people 15 bucks but you
also have to imagine that half of that
is going to their [__] rent yeah
that's what it is half of that I don't
even see the profit margin there was a
great documentary called Deli man about
the rise of all the great Jewish delies
over the last 150 years and how they're
all going out of business cuz the the
cost of goods are everything's too
expensive your margins are so so small
that you you could have a thousand
customers in a day and still not make I
could go to where my wife is from the
town over is Bradford Tennessee mhm
there's a mall where there's a Chinese
buffet there's a Walmart but guess what
in that strip mall there's four places
that are wide open right I could go in
and tell the guy listen cut one of these
in half this is what I'm goingon to do
I'm gonna have a coffee shop here l
chocolate white milk uh the [__] that
coffee bean sells the Black Forest y
maybe uh but keep it simple what I'm
really pushing is the regular coffee yep
two a little bit of cream and two scoops
of sugar get the [__] out of here I'm
not going to sit here with syrups and
all this greasy [__] but I'm also going
to have danishes for them and I'm also
going to have an egg sandwich for them
which the profit margin I through the
roof through the roof an egg is what 25
cents [__] bun is what 10 and what's
a a slice of cheese and what's a [__]
uh you know that's it and a piece of
tailor ham yep and you could do it $4.95
and throw in a cup of coffee I could
sell 200 of those in the daytime that's
my specialty in life yeah $4.95 and a
one egg sandwich made by Uncle Joey on
the grill right here fresh New Jersey
Style with the aluminum foil and I cut
it with the aluminum foil like a [__]
doctor that'd be great that's the way
you do it and but to have that I would
have to have sufficient coverage in the
bank and time and I would give myself
time because the things I've gotten
involved with in my life I would give
myself time I knew that it would take
time I'd have to join the social media
thing yeah marketing SP a lot of money
advertising well not even a lot of money
it's just being visible yeah being
visible and convincing people to come in
for a couple coffee and not charging
them 450 right I'm not pushing $4 coffee
here I'm keeping it simple I believe you
would be great in any of those business
cuz they're personality drink so people
would come and just to hang out with you
sit down get a cup of coffee talk [__]
blah blah blah I love something you
would be so good at that the last 10
years of my life I would love to do
something like that I think it would be
for a guy like me I love it you know i'
love to open up a Cuban restaurant but
it would be one thing a day I would be
open for breakfast for Hamond eggs or
Cuban whatever breakfast I'd make up a
Cuban bowl or
whatever I'd have like uh
eggs a
steak white rice a 8 O steak and two
eggs fried on top of it and you cut it
like that and let the yolk go all over
the steak and the white rice that's
Cuban stuff well I eat it delici not in
a million years and I throw you three
fried bananas you know one of those
things I'll throw you a Cuban egg
sandwich for breakfast and that's
breakfast and then for lunch make one
specialty a day
poo on Friday make some type of fish you
know beef tongue on Thursday and it
changes every day when it's done it's
done when it's done it's done you're not
going to come in here and go well do you
have it without the peppers listen this
is how it owns one of the best pizza
places in Philly they only make so many
Do's every day you got to call in
advance to reserve your dough and when
they're done they're done that's it
goodbye we're done we're close we don't
have time to play games with people
because you don't have nothing to lose
you're not looking to be Johnny Bananas
you're at the side of a road in
Tennessee somewhere and you got to get
rednecks to coming and go man this is
the best thing sandwich I've ever had in
my life you know like yeah it is and all
you start talking to them they tell you
they World War II Viet and they they
hate Japanese people you [__] nod
your head you know you don't agree but
you nod your head you know what I'm
saying you don't say you hate Japanese
people but you go yeah you're right and
they come in every day for a cup of
coffee give you an ear beaten and then
they go home and then they start
Gathering there next thing you know you
got 20 old guys Gathering talking [__]
drinking coffee old guys go out for
breakfast bar they're bars for old dud
but they're always looking for 15% off
the old Gees they catch you with that
sunrise breakfast that kills you you
know there was a place of block away
from Golds and Venice they would do 50%
off omelets from like 5:30 in the
morning to 6:30 all the old guys would
be in there 545 oh I was going to say
were they there at 525 with their with
their waiting knocking on the window
papers under their arms ready to go and
in like suits it's so good it's
tremendous and that that's what I would
do and you know how great your podcast
would be just interviewing those
oldtimers that would would doing podcast
you just be done done i' do a little
standup on Wednesdays for
lunch three people I'll work the grill
for you hire me no employees I'm a
oneman show I'm like that strip club in
[__] Portland I went in Oregon years
ago with Josh Wolf the chick did
everything she was the DJ the hostess
she took your money at the door she was
the door man she was the bouncer she
there was a oneman operation she's
playing the drums with her friend it was
[__] hysterical yeah that's it that's
really it you fry how long does it take
it's the most personal thing in the
world you throw on your eggs you talk a
little bit you how do you want your eggs
hen me I want them Sunny Side Up don't
give me a bun today Joey yeah just give
me 10% off you get dick you know cream
cheese and jelly on a roll and you re
you reintroduce culture you know you
reintroduce a menu to people as we say
all the time you impose your willly this
is when you're impose your will you say
I have the best this this is Lee said it
best we were talking about the 800 lb
man that I watched the hour and a half
super siiz special on Friday night it
was one of the most interesting things I
ever watched I mean that show is so
[__] sad every time I watch my 600 lb
life I watch it and I do push-ups I do
[__] sit commercials I mean you just
feel bad but the guy was eating eight
pizzas a day and he weighed 740 and his
brother weighed 6
H 600 lb and the brother had the [__] on
his legs and the brother was born with a
crooked leg this guy had the things on
his leg or whatnot I don't even know
what the point of this [__] story is
I'm telling you about the the the
[__] food he was eating he was eating
eight pizzas a
day what the [__] was I going to tell
you you're talking about imposing your
will this is the best no we're talking
about I don't know the Armenian doctor I
have no [__] idea this is why you I'm
lucky I have you tonight
cuz I don't you don't get high thank you
to be there I got well definitely one
time Arian Ren his easy hot boxed me
when I was driving to get Chinese food I
almost killed us and I was just
laughing there's a Chinese food place
that stays open late in R it's not bad
it's not good the vibe is tremendous but
they hot boox me there and then once
when we were in Denver Ari gave me a
joint and I took one hit and I fell
asleep for two
hours I was out I was out to the
world I forgot what I was going to
[__] tell you about the [__] 800
lb man but anyway who gives a [__] you
you just said something that I wanted to
talk about uh imposing your
will I was think going back to a kid I
never really asked I'm not really good
at being at asking for what I
want is that is that something that you
guys have gotten better at and asking
and like like I know you guys are
improving in your careers asking for
roles I don't know is that
you want me to help want me to tell you
what creates that mental thing of
imposing your will once you've known
you've done the
work once you
known you've done the work that's when
you get so confident at what you do and
you're so assertive on it listen Lee I
have the same problems that you have I
deal with the same things you have I
don't like asking for money
I don't like asking for money yeah and
you always think that you know what I'll
give this person a break but I'll make
it up here you know there's always these
little mental blocks in your
head and then you realize that these
people Tak advantage of you they're
taking advantage of you it's not even
fair anymore you know what I'm saying I
had a situation last week where we asked
for more money for a certain thing this
is after they asked us to help them with
their slogan or some [__]
and we said yeah we'll help you but you
have to pay us and then I asked him for
a r and the guy's like no and I'm
thinking to myself so wait a second when
you were paying us peanuts and we were
doing great you never you never called
us and said this is what you got extra
money right now that we're asking you
you don't want to do it guess what now I
don't want to do business with you you
proved who you were and it pro imposed
my will I did my work I get up early
every week I I look for music I have to
talk to guests you know I have to get
here there's a lot of work that goes
into there's a lot of work that goes
into everything you know I bust Le balls
I let I bust Le balls because I was Lee
at 28 also and I know the mistakes you
make and the stupid moves that we do I
mean I did such a stupid move I ended in
prison at 25 so I goof on Lee not to
goof on Lee because I get off on goofing
on Lee I goof on Lee so Lee sees the
shortcut M but you know what nobody ever
sees the shortcut to [__] late and it
would break my heart to see Lee get hurt
in anyway I can see this kid like a son
you know I love to stab him and put him
in the trunk of my car like Billy bats
time to time but on the other hand I
never want anything bad to happen to him
in any
situation you know
you were [__] horrible when we're 20
you know we think we have the World by
the balls and all this stuff and
something dawned on me this week and
Saturday
night it's so weird that this type of
[__] really irritates the [__] out of me
because I don't understand if people
understand
okay I watched something and he said
this is what turns players into Kings
and it dawned on me for a long time what
the expression made for years I told it
around
Hollywood for years I tow it around
Hollywood like everybody else tiptoes
around Hollywood mhm I didn't want to
piss nobody off I didn't really want to
ask for more money I didn't want to do
this and then one day you snap something
really happens in your brain and you
cover all your bases and you work harder
but it's called
sacrifice you know I don't think people
especially people like Lee know what
sacrifice
is sacrifice is a big word word to get
to the next level I don't give a [__]
what anybody tells you you have a mom m
Steve M yeah is your mom alive yes thank
God is your dad alive thank God you you
have your brothers your siblings yep
where do they live 3,000 mil away that's
sacrifice absolutely you don't need this
you don't need on a Monday night to be
sitting between a Jew and a Cuban
getting tormented in [__] North
Hollywood California to go to the comedy
store to pick up a check for $15
absolutely your parents Mar your
grandparents migrated here to this
country to be a better thing your
brother became a dentist I'm not putting
you down I'm not saying this but you
sacrificed this you slept with fat
[__] James in his apartment smelling
his fat [__] feet in his ass and
years which were worse than those Jews
on the plane I didn't have a car I took
the bus for 6 years I have sacrifice
sacrifice is all your friends go home
for Christmas and I'm working at the
Hollywood gym night night shift it
bothers me that nobody understands that
you know I had a a dear friend die three
weeks ago not dear no no no it was a
friendship that I loved her dearly and
alcohol and mental health took us
somewhere else it's a very sad thing I
had a block her on my phone yeah so I'm
not going to sit here and tell you you
know she was my best friend in the world
I had to block her off my phone I got
too many things in my life for you to be
calling me 18 times while I'm on stage
right to break my [__]
balls and I got a little slack for it
for not going to the memorial this week
okay but I also remember where these
people came from these people moved to
to to to a to Colorado uh to Los Angeles
in a group they they went 15 deep out of
Houston Texas but nobody wanted to
sacrifice they didn't want to sacrifice
the most important things for the most
important thing the reason why you're
here y you know before I got on stage
Saturday night there was these great
funny guys and they're like hey man we
brought you reefer we brought you this
where are we going to and I go I can't
[__] go nowhere I got a 545 flight to
New York and they're like can't you call
your wife and put it off for one I goes
I told him I go this has nothing to do
with my wife I don't give a [__] about
my wife this has to do with me because I
got to that means I got to fly at 12:00
to get home at 6:00 I'm not going to
have any sleep my kid plus I got an
audition Monday morning right you know
oh no I'm just going to steam it and get
off the plane and go to CBS Radford and
after I stayed out with [__] people
smoking dope and talking about nothing
right because at the end of the day
that's what you're doing is talking
about nothing you I did this I wasted
that time for [__] 30 years I'm not
going to sit here and get on a high
horse and tell you no no no no no I
wasted enough [__] time but in this
town once I took control of me y I
always sacrificed yeah I made the
biggest sacrifice I looked at a
5-year-old little girl one day in the
park and I told her that I'm really
thinking of going away for a while that
I think it would be better and she spit
in my face my daughter my daughter
that's 27 years old when I when I told
her about my my dream she spit in my
face on a
bicycle and that was the biggest
sacrifice I made I made a sacrifice to
say I'll give up my daughter to do
something with my life okay and then I
came here and while these people were
all drinking early yeah even though I
was a junky Coke feain I could C off
till 11:30 12 and I remember you doing
late night TS and being up call me once
because you found something on the
breakdowns you were waking up Ear going
over the breakdowns on your own no I was
an animal and I didn't go to weddings
and I didn't go to wakes and I didn't do
a lot of things yeah and I'm sure I'm
sure along the way I disappointed a lot
of people yeah because I didn't attend
their wedding or whatever function they
had or because they had a party you know
when this changed it's because my head
changed explain that my head changed it
snapped you realize but this happened
way before Mercy this was happening two
years before I met Lee okay
it h i always sacrificed let's get
something wrong
you I always sacrificed I sacrificed
holidays let me tell you something this
weekend when I went home and I saw my
friends and I saw like Steve a villo and
Alan Pasqual and and and [__] Carlos
and Abe Garcia I realized something that
yes I'm very happy out here but I'm very
lonely out here they're a different type
of breed this is this is what home is
all about I agree with you I know up
with and I can't replace somebody that
knew what you were Halloween in second
grade they remember what your house
smelled like on a Sunday yeah you cannot
replace that so I see all these guys and
when I get on the plan I go that's what
I sacrifice and don't get me wrong I
made a lot of mistakes to force myself
to leave there in a subtle way I want I
I wanted to leave there like I I
couldn't I was embarrassed I wouldn't
ever became anything there I knew I had
the same feeling but the sacrifice I had
was to not to lose my friends to not
have them in my life Timmy hallay those
type of people the weddings you missed
the birthday the wedings the birthdays
the parties I missed all that [__] so
that was the first sacrifice I made then
I sacrificed my relationship with my
daughter I knew when I got in that car
and I left B I wasn't coming back and
deep in my heart I knew that I would
just get in trouble there I would just
end up in a bad position there and it
was time for me to cleanse myself of all
that and if this relationship I prayed
to God I wanted to prove to her that I
was worth something longterm goal was
bigger than the short-term satisfaction
they say the secret to success is
delaying gratification and you know if
you stayed there you couldn't be the
person you would be proud of not at all
not at all so then you wanted to do
something with your life to show her how
much you really do love her that's what
I'm getting from you got to do that
sometimes it was uh it was [__] real
like it was just something
that you know I sacrificed I remember
you know Josh Wolf dear friend of mine
all those years had had parties on
satday nights with his family and Scott
wolf and all these other actors and the
singers from the Counting Crows that
didn't mean anything to me I was at the
comedy store you know what I had to get
$50 so I would go down and do filipe's
room and then get to The Comedy Store
for my 11:45 on Saturday and then you
know you
sacrificed and I partied I'm not going
to lie to you that but even though I
partied I made my auditions I took care
of things I I you know I I I took care
of things the best I could yeah after I
got off the coke like in 2009 before I
married Terry is where this came this
picture became clearer to me that I even
had to sacrifice more like I had to
sacrifice more like I went to Weight
Watches I joined karate with the
brothers in 2007 I was going I was I was
four I was 380 when I walked in there I
remember doing horse dances and my knees
would [__] burn they would make you
do these Dr Dron stances where you drag
one foot and kneel on this one I would
have to go home and put two bags of
[__] ice on my knees but I knew that
these were little sacrifices I had to
get make to get to where I wanted to be
it was the the weirdest [__] thing
well that was that just like an
intuition that you had kind I went back
to my karate days I went back to how
successful I was when I attended
karate from the ages of six to the age
of of
15 wow you did it your whole childhood
yeah when I dropped out of karate was
when I got left back in the seventh
grade Mind Body Soul that reconfirmed
everything so I knew for me to get back
to my mental state I had to pick a
martial art I looked for a Kempo school
I couldn't find one so the best kept
secret in Hollywood was this guy this uh
style of kung fu mixed with Kempo the
Hawaiian Kempo and they just make me get
loose I just went to to get my day
started and I said and I
and I said to myself for me to do this
and be
successful nothing could take the place
of this unless I'm picking up an
envelope yes build your foundation so I
went back to the war of art The Art of
War whatever that book is I went back
to if I'm not doing something good for
me I'm in the house writing and there's
no resistance the only way I can get out
of kung fu is if I'm making money or
it's something to make money not to meet
somebody about a script everything get
find myself wasting so much time
everything gets pushed back everything
gets pushed back for this nothing is as
important as that and I started with
that if I could do it just on Mondays
then I would go Mondays and Tuesdays and
I wasn't on the road then yeah so I
would go three days a week by Friday my
knees would be swollen then I popped the
one knee and I got knee surgery and I
went to way you know but you sacrifice
so many little things along on the way
there was a lot of times yes I wanted to
go meet faan and this guy and go get
sandwiches and you don't do that anymore
because that time is for writing now
yeah and you know that time is dictated
to writing that's what that time is
about you know T after dinner for about
35 minutes I always go in and I look
over the book that's great and I write
two sentences and even though I want to
sit there with my wife and watch World
news tonight there's nothing on World
News Tonight that's going to change my
life anymore the first 15 minutes are
about
or something stupid that's not going to
do anything at all to me but it's
amazing that people think they're really
going to get ahead in this life without
making sacrifices it drives me crazy it
drives me crazy how you have to you know
what yes on paper life is Monday through
Friday well that's a great thought
that's a great [__] thought that's a
great thought but when you're 44 you're
going to find yourself $30,000 in credit
card debt y on a fixed [__] income if
you go 10 if you get a flat tie you're
done for the [__] month y because you
you leave your credit cards just enough
room for emergencies and all that [__]
and how do you know cuz it happened to
me yeah when these N9 to5 [__]
especially from the ages of 20 to 35
unless you're making a lot of [__]
loot there's no N9 to5 in my world I
don't understand that [__] you know and
again that's what I had to learn the
hard way right you know what I'm saying
those are the things that we think
Society no no no no no you know when
you're first training in your job
remember you work Saturdays and it sucks
when you're a kid y it sucks working
Saturdays when you're a kid especially
you like going out on Friday night and
drinking some VOD tonics and waking up
hungry coming in late to your house it
sucks waking up when you're in the
[__] a junior in high school to go
sell paint or work at [__] foot
construction site or something yeah it
sucks but then you for a while you're
young and you're a football fan and
you're like well I'll never work on
Sundays well think again [__] that
shit's going to sail pretty [__] soon
you know especially in high school like
the jobs you can get in high school I I
worked at a CVS I worked at a movie
theater you have to be there early what
about like I can't imagine star working
at a coffee place where you have to be
there by like what 3:00 in the morning
they open up this one here at 4:30 to
drive-thru opens wow so what what time
do you think people get there open 3:45
oh my God turn all the buttons on
yeah but you figure you're out of there
by 10 if you're a
student that's a sacrifice if you're but
if you're a
student like you should be busy all the
time yeah like if you're a student a
real student and you're putting yourself
through or you you have a couple loans
and your parents are helping you you got
to have a job I would work at Starbucks
from FL to [__] and what do you
sacrifice your stupid night life it's
amazing how you get the one puzzle piece
and it makes other ones fall in line
right in [__] fall in line Falls in
line because now you can't make as many
dumb decisions because now you have the
responsibility of being up early all
those things start to change your life
you get karate down and then your body
starts getting stronger and then your
mind gets stronger then every it all
works together it is and it's so weird
because you'll say to yourself well I
really can't do that because this is
what I do on those days and all of a
sudden you're like you know what doing
what I was doing didn't bring me
anything yeah until you really started
sacrifice and then listen a couple weeks
ago I missed a wedding of like a sister
of mine but you know what
man I had to think about my time I had
to think about my age I had to think
about what was going on that Monday I
had to meet them Sunday and discuss the
pitch the pictures at 9:30 in the
morning I had to leave at [__] A4 to
6 I mean there was so many things
involved I sacrificed the wedding you
know I mean it was always things like
that with me that I would force myself
not to do something I would really enjoy
yeah you know you said something earlier
and like it didn't hurt my feelings but
he said like people likely I don't think
understand what it is to sacrifice and
for a second I was
like your age your grou I understand
that your group but like but I started
thinking about it like there is a point
I think
every six months a year where you're
like I am sacrificing but not
sacrificing enough so like well like you
can take different things out like the
benge watching orig just the new black
Nine episodes in a in a day that you
can't do that anymore you can't no no no
no no no nobody ever said that that's
not a sacrifice that's a Leisure and for
you to entertain you have to entertain
it's when you do that six days a [__]
week right okay okay it's when you do
that six days a week for me to sit on
Sundays and watch 60 minutes and what's
the show with Pete holes
crashing crash okay I watch crashing I
watched the show you know why I watch
television on Sunday nights I earned it
I did two podcasts I traveled halfway
across the country I did five shows I
talked to 200 people per show I took my
pictures and I sacrifice three days
without my family when I get off that
plane I do the same thing every time I
go to the room I set up my sleep apne
machine I throw my dirty laundry in the
[__] hamper for my wife so she
doesn't have to see it I put my suitcase
away I jumped in the [__] shower I go
I set the notebook up for the week I
know exactly what my schedule's going to
be for the week I answer a few emails
and any unnecessary things I got to do I
write out my thing and I don't sit in
that [__] office the rest of the
goddamn day I earned that I earned that
on Sunday and even then I won't let
myself do stupid things I'll sit in the
backyard with mercy and I'll kick the
[__] soccer ball and I'll watch
[__] when they I'll take a nap from
2:00 to 4:00 and then when I wake up at
4:00 I watch an episode of an you have
to do that or I'll watch the New England
Patriot game a quarter I'll call you and
tell you yeah I call I can't sit there
if I didn't [__] earn
it and only you know when you earned it
I did two podcast I wrote [__] jokes
I went to Jiu-Jitsu twice I did a drill
class I I I drove Mercy to school Monday
Tuesday Wednesday I picked her up Monday
Tuesday Wednesday I I ate 2,000
milligrams on Monday I ate 2,000
milligrams on Thursday
you know I worked out in the hotel
Friday and Saturday I left the hotel
room and went to the coffee shop and
forced myself to write for an hour and a
half on both [__] days Sunday I when
I get off that plane it's the same every
[__] Sunday if you call me on Sunday
with a story about this or this you're
in no danger of me going I cannot go to
your [__] function or I'm not going
to do a set because I did everything on
that [__] checklist that's the only
way when I watch TV there's a foot stol
it's to the side for me to get up my
feet on that foot stol I gotta work for
it that's great I gotta work for it and
that's it and I don't think I've read it
I've heard about it how the younger
generation doesn't understand the
sacrifice you know uh I just read this
the other day something about well they
were picking on Millennials which
everybody [__] picks on it's no fair
you know what I'm saying but no
everybody picks on [__] Millennials
but Millennials are young right so you
don't call them Millennials just say
kids they're [__] 25 year olds and I
always ask myself Joey what the [__]
were you doing to 25 I wasn't doing what
Lee was doing I was selling cars and
making Seven Grand a month but I was
also snorting an eight ball of coke and
I could I had a monkey on my back I
couldn't control how uncontrollable it
was I put a machine gun to somebody and
thought I was going to get away with
kidnapping them and taking a kilo of
coke that's how delusional I was so I
understand the 20s don't call them
millennials don't do that to these
[__] idiots when everybody's 25
they're [__] confused we're [__]
idiots and we accept that [__] I've said
a thousand times the 30s or the clean up
the mess you made [__] 20 plain and
[__] simple so no Lee I was in and
and well I was not insulting you at all
I was comparing it to your age oh no and
even if you even if you were to me cuz I
there are things that I have to do and
even even when you do earn
it I think there's a certain thing like
that you choose to do I was thinking I
was thinking last week I don't really
have a hobby and I know Jiu-Jitsu isn't
a hobby it's a sport but we had things
as kids that we did and even though I'm
not athletic like even if I I I I still
have to work out but I should I was I've
been thinking about looking for
something outside of what I do just to
get my mind off I I don't I think
that'll be a good thing for you I I
don't know why adults stop doing that
adult stop doing what having some sort
of Hobby and you you have to
adults do have hobbies we just don't
hang out or associate with people with
Hobbies there's guys that every Saturday
they get on their motorcycles yeah and
they meet for coffee they take a ride
around the park and they talk about
their motorcy people that Golf and I
can't tell you how very important it is
and I learned how important it is the
last three
years I learned how important it is the
years you you get delusional it's bad to
be around the people you work you know
think about if you're a coal miner in
Pennsylvania I have nothing against coal
miners and I have nothing against
Pennsylvania but you're around the same
people for the rest of your [__] life
when you're off work how many bars are
there in those towns four right you're
either at one of them you're talking
about your boss you're talk about the
shitty mistakes that the foreman make
you talk about how you should be a
foreman you know what I'm saying it's
constant but it's also a a small town
mentality they call it I don't call it
that that's what they call a small small
town mentality when you're
here from
1997 to
204 I didn't want to talk to you if you
didn't do what I did I had no use for
you mhm as a human being I was trying to
learn everything I could as much as I
could about this business and get as far
as I could I got so involved in it that
I gained over a 100 pound and didn't
even see it people get obsessed
I got obsessed you get obsessed I got
obsessed with the breakdowns I got
obsessed on why I wasn't getting the
things everybody else was getting I
wasn't angry at no one it's a big
difference I was angry till 2001 and
then after that I became angry that I
didn't think I was getting the things I
deserved but who the [__] was I didn't
even deserve anything you know what I'm
saying like I balanced it out but I got
so into what I did which was 30 to 40
spots a month
that's incredible 30 to 40 spots a month
you figure five a week at the store
whatever Rogan took me for and all the
Felipe and the Fly and the Jeff Garcia
and the Willy bar Center rooms what do
you think an average comedian does
here real
spots listen if they're doing two spots
a night six nights a week figure it out
who's doing that though Bill Chris deia
yeah the girl the blonde
Eliza uh just to have that opportunity
though you got to be like on the top of
the pile to get that stage not really
Tommy Easter could do 30 spots a week if
he wanted to open mics yep yeah you know
you watch that show crashing people talk
[__] about the show crashing one thing
it reminds me it reminds me
of 94 1993 it was a cold reality for me
what Pete's going through right now you
know you got a bark on the side for me
it was you had to sell tickets at half
price on the street doesn't change the
hustle didn't change just became
something else yeah so I would go to the
comic strip I would go to the New York
comedy club and they give you a bunch of
tickets and you have to sell them you
know what I did I kept all the money and
never went back you know you know me dog
I'm a [__] piece of [__] and I would
I would I would keep $100 and I didn't
give a [__] about the comic sh I don't
need you people I'll do my work around
you people I'll come back and after I
get an B special that never happened but
you know it's it's never really changed
so it's been reminding me and they kind
of got it they really do have it Pete's
doing a great job I'll have to check it
out and I think that the they have it
you know the feeling the
frustration Pete got divorced his wife
cheat on him cuz he's broke and he's
kind of ubot yeah same thing like me and
then you have no money and you crashing
on people's couches yeah you know he
just crashing on people's couches and on
the way you meet different people I met
Doug Stan hope I met that guy Lee Camp
from New York that teaches standup
comedy you meet different people along
the path and and if they're real
stand-ups they show you love Yeah you
could stay on my couch you know yeah you
could you borrow my car you know when I
first came to La Doug Stan hope had a
car you could just go over there and get
in it that's great but the needle was
broken so you always never knew how much
gas was in there you never knew
sometimes it didn't even make the gas
station some sometimes didn't even make
the gas station where's Tony B
Co look at this look at this you see
what I'm talking about so
cute I want to be
around to pick up the
pieces when some breaks
your what's up
dog doing good
man ready for another bong hit no yeah
we got to do one more I almost died
that's the good thing thank you that's
the good
thing this is a great reef oh
[__] that's for
you it's green it's tiny I know it's
look at
that learn
my issue isn't that it's too big no it's
it's the weed you like I feel I made it
small for you okay nobody gets their
feelings H this is for the [__]
Spence Fool's Day you didn't do a bong
hit I did I did to do bong hit n April
Fool's Day it was Saturday you were up
at Lake Canon wherever the [__] you
were Hotel he stayed an hour away from
the hotel down theill to save 15 before
I take the bong head can we go here we
go first of all the hotels up there
looked nice but a little bit older it it
was a little bit expensive so we stayed
an hour away so we wouldn't have to be
stuck with uh just uh maybe the hotel
food options so but anyways Grand Canyon
was amazing listen you need to scab off
a Syrian refugees head you understand me
you called me to ask me usually Chinese
buffet so all of a sudden now you care
about food up the up the [__] C it
was next to it was next to a gas station
so I couldn't do it but why can't you
stand next to a gas station I just now
for a Chinese buffet and it didn't and I
yeled it didn't have good reviews oh
really you yeled it I finally lied to
you huh I tried rattlesnake though did
you try rattlesnake it was delicious it
was it was good but it was it was it was
uh I tried like one bite we the
restaurant even only puts it out in 2
ounces because they like they know we're
not going you're not going to finish it
you're going to take one bite and did
your wife like it what does it taste
like
it was spicy but I I couldn't tell if
there were scales still on it but but
granted granted I I had a couple stars
in me cuz we were up at the Grand k i do
the BN you killing me you're killing me
what am I doing [__] rattlesnake and
never ends it never ends it never
ends where'd you do this laugh or the
other place the Grand Canyon oh okay I
would know got to do the bong please
okay what you going to irate me
pH look at this look at this come here
come here come here cuz I'm going to
strangle you come here come here he's
not going to do it right come here stay
right come here stay right there bend
over come here unbelievable cook this
cook that [__] cook that
[__] cook that [__]
there you go like a
soldier
wa there you go finish that thing there
you go that's beautiful that
reefer that's the [__] that kill Steve
SWOT you know Steve SWOT is the him my
bu Steve Sone Stone give me the [__]
thing will you oh my God got some good
reefer right there and [__] no but
that's what really kills me
that I don't understand if people really
know before what they get themselves
into I can't believe I really don't get
it how many people show up and then
don't want to do the work like you come
all the way here you say you want to do
comedy you know how many people I've
invited down to The Comedy Store open
the mic on a Monday explained everything
to them and they never come back they
come back 6 months later yeah I'm
thinking about getting back into it do
you know how many people that went see I
got here in 97 with you from 96
to oh about 2002 people the network
would give you a thing that's called
developmental deal mhm okay a
developmental deal meant you were hot
the networks called you and said we'd
like to speak to see Steve Simone Steve
Simone would show up he would pitch him
an idea they'd say they love it they
come that Thursday and want you do
standup and next thing you know you'd
ink a deal for a TV series based on your
stand up that's unbelievable it was a
year deal for example first you got to
find the show run that jiz is with
you then you got to find the writer that
jiz is with you in between whatever
project he has and then you got to write
the pilot and you get your money in
levels so let's say it's like a $250,000
deal you get a 100 down and another
50,000 when the Pilot's done then you
pick up another 50,000 when the pilot
just shot and you pick up another 50,000
when the pilot is aired wow so it all
goes in levels people all get different
developmental deals people just get a
flat fee then you have a year or two to
develop your own show I think that the
tough part about living and working here
but not being on the uh Talent side
because like the money that's thrown
around and that you hear even not even
for de development deals but just like
so and so got paid $20 million I
remember in high school Will Smith was
getting $20 million a movie and just to
hear that and like what what are you
talking like that's not even you can't
even really fathom that number $20
million you know what you have to
produce to be valued at $20 million
worlda that's like Tom Cruz money that's
like you know that's when you sell
records worldwide that's where you put
asses in seats like a Tom Cruz like a
Will Smith Will Smith worldwide
you know that you make that company $500
million on your $20 million investment
right you know but that's just you they
also have to do marketing and shoot the
film and all the production you know
somebody like robbert dairo who's a
phenomenal actor nobody goes to the
movies to watch anymore unless you like
the art of
acting so Robert's not getting $20
million he could probably wipe the
[__] floors Will Smith but it really
doesn't matter you know Dave Vel is a
phenomenal [__] comedian but if young
kids don't like
him right nobody goes to see him he
could eat every comic working lunch
today you follow me even on his bad
night yeah he's amazing but that's just
the way life is I really don't like that
stat like the uh how much money the
movie makes I'd really rather it be how
many tickets it sold because they I
honestly think they raised ticket prices
just to set records just to be like they
can say they said hit a billion dollars
either way it's like Revenge I could
either hit you in the head to blow up
your car the result is the same you know
what I'm saying yeah I'm in the Revenge
business shut the [__] up boy it's they
don't care how many tickets it's the
money yeah what's the general cost now
that also includes with a comedian
remember Ralphie came on here Ralphie
said that he signed with his manager the
manager pulled him out of all the
improvs
for a year just kept him out of the
improvs and then he found out through
the IRS what the people were making for
real and the real books not what they
tell you that they made at the door but
what you made selling food and what you
made the real
GPR so his manager attacked that
number you know there there there's some
people that don't have the talent you
have Steve Simone but they have a better
manager who negotiates a better deal and
one day sound like Mickey and Rocky
right now never how to manag yeah know
it's the same difference it's the same
[__] difference you know it's the
same difference he could have a manager
and for you to jump out in that window
in that movie they'll give you $200 for
him to jump out the same window and do
the same stunt they negotiate $88,000
unless ABS yeah they don't [__] know
you never [__] know so it's it's it's
for you to pay Will Smith $20 million is
because you got to get 10 times your
investment back on Will Smith After All
costs and everything there's no how many
write offs has Will Smith had the last
10 years the one movie not with the
black kid not when he was a a computer
wiz with his kid yeah the happiness one
yeah there was just maybe one movie that
he didn't do well with you know but all
his movies do well that if they don't do
well here they do well internationally
that's where your money is that's where
your main paper is just because that you
know how many times have you heard
Mickey rock is huge in
France yeah you know he's huge in France
like who the [__] what was the guy from
the guy from Jerry Lewis no hasselhof
Germany Germany he was [__] huge he
was worth you know it's not for the
American audience sometimes it's
basically for the [__] International
audience yeah Will Smith went dark for a
little bit kind of not really but like
he he was really busy and then between
like he did like one movie a year 06 07
and then he didn't do anything for four
years until
2012 but he's uh he's always been good
okay let me explain something to you
that's called
strategy that's called I'm going to get
$20 million a movie I could I could do
three movies in one year and two of them
out the three could bomb and then I
lower it down to 7 million right or I
could do once a year come up with a good
script have my agent show up with
something good that'll do well here and
great internationally I have to jump off
a few buildings I'm going have to eat
some steroids get a dog whatever the
[__] it is that's called The Smarts of
it you
know let's talk about Will Farrell and
the other
guy he was hot in Hell 10 years ago John
fa's friend Steve Burn's friend oh yeah
Vince F there was a time when they put
him in every [__] movie yeah and you
sat there kept saying when is this going
to
end when is this going to end you know
nobody could tell you what movies to
take and what movies you can't take but
you and your head should know that the
more you throw against the wall
something's going to stick yeah
percentage wise uh people talk bad about
Adam sand now it bothers the [__] out of
mean because they don't know how great
of a guy he is but you can't be 100% all
the time and you can't release two
movies a [__] year and expect for all
of them to bring win the Oscars so
sometimes you have to be a little
smarter than that same applies to Comedy
the same applies to advertising on
television the same applies to how long
people want to see you over and over and
over again you get Overexposed I don't
do Periscope every day it's not
necessary I'm not [__] Brad Pit
nobody needs to see my [__] face
every [__] day but I know this going
in right there's people who get on
Periscope every day and overstay their
welcome it's the same thing with movies
if you do three movies a year in today's
market where I have so much
entertainment so many options so many
options so many options every time I
release a movie they can't make $138
billion truth I'm going up against film
TV Netflix shroom
text text Hulu Twitter Twitter I'm going
up against everything I think that's why
I think it's smart he did what he did
with signing with Netflix because it's
it not it's more it's about uh
International and like you said and
about streams just to talk about Adam
Sandler for a second I watch I rewatched
Happy Gilmore last night so good [__]
hilarious hilar
KS me time and the [__] thing about
Adam Sandler was that I couldn't watch
this guy until I met him and after I met
him was when I watched like Mr Deeds
loved all that I watched Gore once I
watched all that [__] I I got to
understand who he was and I really
appreciate who he was and now like the
other day somebody wrote people writing
[__] to him on on Twitter and it drives
me nuts like the other day somebody
wrote he got a deal last week didn't he
he he re up with
I and people were insult to them and I'm
like you have no idea who this guy is
what happened was they went to the well
a little bit too much that genre of
funny you know when Adam Sandler doesn't
do his
movies he's [__] tremendous Adam sand
a punch drunk love Yeah punch drunk he
so good in that bro Adam sand a rock
with the best him I don't give a [__]
what anybody tells you I was there with
him I saw what he could do I saw his
sense of humor and I also saw the
attraction how he made you laugh he's so
likeable on the on the movie the first
couple years I couldn't look at ad him s
for 10 seconds I want to throw there
when people would go I like Adam sand I
would stop talking to them I would stop
talking to him when I met that man and I
saw him on the set and I saw him
work I was like God damn like that's how
free he was so free and I admired him so
much for that yeah and listen so what I
don't get invited to his Christmas party
so no more snow what he hasn't put me in
his last 10 movies I can't hold any of
that to him because what he did for me
on The Longest Yard he went above and
beyond for me I'll never ever forget
that to the Grave I'll never forget just
getting to hang out with you one day on
the SAT was the greatest best field trip
I've ever been on oh my God I I'll never
forget that so I respect them but it's
the same thing man you can't fight three
times a year right Donald Cerone learned
that this year you cannot fight three
times a year a year and there you have
to ask yourself the why and the how I
got an offer today from San Diego I'm
going to tell you guys the truth these
people wanted me to charge 55 bucks for
tickets VIP seating 35 for general
admission and $20 for 200 people to
stand I told them to take that deal and
show it up their ass good for you they
were like are you serious I'm like I
would never charge I don't give a [__]
what is wrong with people yeah but then
people can't realize what happens
because we get talked into stupid [__]
we get LED down wrong
streets I I I see it coming from every
direction that's how they get you is
with the money and you start looking at
the money going $55 I don't care about
these people don't it's like I've been
getting hit the last couple weeks I'm at
that [__] Turner Hall but when you
click on Turner Hall on [__] Yahoo to
get tickets all these fake websites come
out and they're charging $216 for
tickets to go see me at a [__]
theater so people sending me these
tweets so I had to finally go to the
[__] thing and it's no it's $20 a
seat $25 a seat I would never charged
but these fake ticket agencies yeah
they're buying tickets and selling them
for $216 [__] dollars like scalpers
or some [__] that fake sites I would
never do that I would never do that at
all that's you got a good heart no not
because they have it's good business
it's good [__] business yeah but they
go hand inand sometimes in life there
are comedians that charge a hundred
[__] dollars for you to go see them I
don't care how funny somebody is I
refuse to pay $100 to go see somebody D
I think what happens is people get
caught up people that maybe did make
those sacrifices you were talking about
and then somewhere along the line they
go well I deserve it or right now it's
my turn but they don't think of that
long-term success like you said take
care of your fans it takes forever to
get fans appreciate them take care of
them that's it and then you can stay in
business forever it's the way I look at
it keep on writing new stuff be nice
nice to people and that's it who knows
if it's true but when I uh there was a
story over the weekend that Mike Tyson
charges uh a couple hundred dollars to
have a picture with him that's like and
you can do whatever you want and and and
but that just
seems a little that goes both ways that
goes both ways
because how many people stop Mike Tyson
yeah
right does he charge the 200 at private
functions when he does a speaking
engagement or if I bump into him right
now on the street at Rouse and I go Mike
let me hook up with a picture of you dud
he was at The Comedy Store one night he
seemed so cool was ridiculous yeah he
seems so cool that's what every story's
been that's what every story I've heard
is that maybe it is for those events
but those like have you ever have you
been approached to go to those picture
signing events Joey yeah years ago when
The Longest Yard came out and I
refused I refused refused I don't see
that I don't want to do that there's
nothing in my heart I want I don't want
to do any of that stuff is that a normal
Feast Steve do you think maybe for that
thing I'm not I'm not I'm not trying
start beef with my years ago that's not
a years ago I heard a comedian charging
$10 for a picture
now there's two ways to attack this I
came up with a comic that didn't want
the audience to see him till he went on
stage you know and he explained to me
why because you want to be bigger than
them and I get it I get it but in my
world I'm not bigger than it right so
you know there's a lot of things that
Big Time comics do to make their
appearance seem a little bigger than
what they are right and it worked for
them it doesn't work for me I appreciate
getting $10 a head shot I could you know
when I got to catch a 3:30 a.m. flight
and there's three people 30 people
online and I'm there for an hour talking
to them it would be great to get $10 a
person and get an extra $300 yeah what
would the $300 do for me beside insult
these poor people yeah what would the
$300 do to ins salty you know what if I
ask them on the way out to give me 10
bucks a piece they give it to me yeah
people that that listen to the church
when they come to a show on the way out
I need 10 bucks or I need the Buy weed
they give it to me yeah you you're going
to charge these people there's little
things that people do that would turn me
off completely I stop going to a
restaurant because they don't clean the
windows I look at the weirdest things
you know right I know if this person's a
businessman or I know if this person's a
[__] Joker by the treatment when
people get their cars [__] up I always
tell people go to
Marco yeah but go to Marco go to Marco I
don't give go to morco you're never
going to be treated like that in your
life yeah now he's Russian Armenian they
get the Bild they get a cent through you
know sometimes we have to call your
insurance and get it
approved go ahead get the car I'll get
it approved I'll make them an offer they
can't I mean like I said he got me a
battery in my car a year later a year
later I told him my battery was dead he
came all the way up here to Comon Street
when I used to live over there and he
[__] put the battery in my car wow
from Glendale takes care of people
that's customer service that's the
greatest thing it's gone in our society
it's gone in our societ I just sent him
my buddy Donnie and Donnie goes I can't
believe Joey what this guy does he save
me my deductible it's amazing it's like
my tax guy I send everybody to he takes
care of you that's Rick guy that went to
jail his
buddy
great you keep sending all these guys to
a prison [__] not the same guy no but
they're guilty to Association birds of a
feather flock together if your friend
went to jail you're [__] close by you
know what I'm saying oh my God yeah keep
it up Le keep it up going I save $3,000
okay wait till you writing me from day
Foley cell over there
[__] y over in the day Foley sweet and
[__] man they don't have no no no no
hummus in here cuz there's no hummus in
prison the only hummus you get is if you
blow an Arab that's the only hummus you
get and you get no nachos there's no
nachos it's just straight up [__] hummus
juice I don't want to know how you get
nachos so don't there's nachos but
you're not going to get those chips
there's not going to be any in there
[__] hilarious great to see you Steve
loveu pleasure brother what else is
going on in your life [__] getting
ready to do a USO tour when are you
leaving uh May for how long I think two
weeks and where you st burn I don't know
where we're going yet but it's like you
know who Gary Cannon is he's a great guy
Gary can open up for Ralphie May yeah
great Steve Burn and uh Bill Crawford
out of Pittsburgh who's fantastic Steve
Cannon opens up to Steve Burn a lot yeah
Gary Canon yep I think Steve uh Steve
Burn has a special coming out next week
he does on what do you know what it is
let's give him a shout out he's a great
guy look it up Lee I was going to
contact him but I don't think I had time
for him I have somebody tomorrow already
and I think his special comes on the 6th
or something like that so he's a great
guy he's family he's church family so if
you love Steve Burn give him a shout out
he's fing great guy he is what's the
name of the special his uh fourth
special tell the damn joke is on
Showtime April 7th at 900 p.m. so that's
Friday night Showtime tape it he's a
good [__] dude so hopefully you'll be
shooting your special soon with a little
Grace from God hope so prayers get store
hopefully you'll do it the right way and
[__] like that that'd be great that
would be amazing no man I just noticed
that lately that these people really
bothered me last week
these people really [__] bothered me
last week with this uh Gathering
because they kind of in a way made me
feel bad for doing what I do and ever
since that this girl lived in La she
always had these drunk parties and I
never went to one of their parties I
loved them dearly I appreciate I always
put my work before it as much as I
wanted to do Coke and as much as I knew
one of them would do coke with you and
suck your dick I knew all these things
about these type of parties I always put
stand up before it I always avoided them
you're on a mission and little by little
but this was 10 years ago I avoided
these people this is 15 years ago even
then when I was deep in the blow yeah I
know that there was no future you know
hanging out with these people yeah as
much as I loved them it was the same
stories over and over again it was there
are two types of people in the city the
people that do that that just party that
want to hang out and go to the beach and
have fun all the time and then there's
people that are like I got something to
prove there's something I want to do
there's something I want to accom is
there something wrong with the attitude
though is there something wrong with it
Lee I know you have a little bit of an
issue with it Le I I don't have an issue
with it it's yeah you do I well okay
it's you growing up you just you're so
this image of N 9 to
five sleeping getting Bagels on Saturday
look I don't I don't even know where I
get Maybe movies who knows where that
stupid image comes from
and sometimes I like that when I'm
thinking about the hobby thing I'm like
I I thought you were going to be a
little bit more negative about it
because you're you're so I've never met
anyone who can go for so
long and so hard and not feel burnt out
maybe you do feel burnt out and you just
work through it I don't know but
it's like I was thinking I I don't I
don't know if I've had a day off this
year in in reality which is good I had I
do have a much more free schedule I'm
not I'm not trying to complain but it
it's it's it's a taxing scheduled to get
used to after 5 days a week at school
not really having to work super hard
getting a a&b's usually the [__] are you
talking about as& bees that went out the
window when you [__] got your diploma
I'm talking about life I I know so yeah
you went to college and you work through
college and now you pay half your loans
and you know you help your parents and
stuff like that you've sacrificed in a
lot of
ways I think that and I'm this podcast
is not about Lee or anybody else I'm
just talking about
sacrifice I think that when I first when
I first met Lee the first six months I
had a problem with Le but it wasn't that
I had a problem with lee lee didn't
really know
if I look back at it today Lee didn't
really know how the game was played Lee
thought that there's running a charity
out there that you do this and this is
what happens and and there's two ways
you could do this there's the wrong way
and there's the [__] wrong way yeah
you know I found out listen you didn't
think I want to SN Coke and be the life
of the party when I was 28 I wanted it
given to me or if it wasn't given to me
I took it yeah I'm not going to sit here
and lie to you
if I wanted to party on a Thursday night
and there was going to be [__] day
and I wanted to try to impress these
losers right I would [__] Steve Simone
over give me an a ball I'll have the
money back tomorrow Joey I need the
money tomorrow cuz I got a cop I bought
it from my brother the dentist yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah I didn't give a [__]
about you I'll go out there if I sell
$200 I'll sell $200 if I snort it all
I'll snort it all and if not he ain't
getting [__] tomorrow you know I'll deal
with Steve he'll call me a thousand
times I'll duck him till Tuesday tell
him I got arrested mhm
it's just so weird but when I first met
Lee he didn't
know he had no
idea he didn't know when we went to New
York and I'm like Lee have the
microphone ready he thought you know
there was a lot of things that Lee Lee
had never been around these things I
tell Lee all the time that this is a
valuable education he's getting he told
me himself that he's worked with a a lot
of other people on
podcasting and they don't understand it
they don't understand it people don't
really understand what they need to do
today it's true people don't know the
intensity that you have to go at
something if you want it you might catch
a break and it may be given to you a
little bit too prematurely yeah but
you're still going to have to go back
and do the work yeah there's no
shortcuts I saw with Margaret Cho Tom
rhods and George haraldo God bless his
soul they all got TV shows given to them
right after the explosion of Roseanne
Bar and Seinfeld mhm and would did these
guys quit no they didn't they still do
stand up except for geralo God Rest his
soul I learned a lot from Tom rhods and
from Margaret show they didn't let that
TV Show cancellation stop him it was
just a bump in the road yep a lot of
people that affects yeah that affects
they're never the same again when you
see them their attitude's a little
different they blame it on the network
they were racially biased Margaret made
some chatter about Al biased or whatever
but she dropped that [__] it wasn't even
worth the chatter wasn't even worth the
chatter CU it's a long-term career it's
like if you have a hot show or nothing
happens with this show you still want to
do this for the rest of your life you
know like Ray Romano had one of the most
successful shows ever but he's still
doing standup Seinfeld's still doing
standup does Ray Romano still do standup
yeah he did a charity show for us last
year and did he yeah it was his first
time ever at The Comedy Store it was
great he was such a nice guy and he
talked about shooting the show show in
New York I forget what show it was but
he started go popping into the seller
and he was saying how much he enjoyed
working stuff out with Comedy Club
audiences cuz the only oh he was working
on that music show yes exactly he was
working on a music show or something
like that yeah and he was talking about
how he loved popping into the clubs
again because he was a New York Comic he
was like I never really cut my teeth he
was like I moved to LA to do TV and he
was like by that point I was just doing
casinos and corporate gigs but he's
still doing all that stuff once you're a
standup I think you're always a standup
that's it well I I love it more now than
I did when I started I just don't have
the ability to do what I was doing when
I started like when I come back next
week I'm not doing the big clubs
anymore I'm going to go on a [__] bar
te again Tuesdays and Thursdays and go
to little bars and start from scratch I
need to come up with a new hour and I'm
not going to come up with at The Comedy
Store I'm not going to come up with a
theem problem I'm not going to come up
with so you want to be off the map a
little bit off the map okay I'm going
back to the haha I'm going to do these
other there's a room close to the house
on Tuesday nights there's another one on
Thursday I'd love to hit any of those
rooms and maybe just hit the store once
a week like I hit it on Saturdays doing
Brian Monarch show to see where I'm
going with the material but I'm not
going to grow if I keep going to Comedy
Store because I got to keep doing a
material to keep up with the masses yeah
so I can't do that just I have to go
back to when I
first I like to shoot a CD a year from
now tape a new
special but the only way I'm going to
tape this special it to be effective is
to take it back to Roots that's cool got
take it back the little rooms and [__]
you know you go to The Comedy Store main
room you got to ham it up I got to ham
it up in the original room and I'm too
old to be Hamming it up during the week
I expected you know and I'm not
complaining I'm just saying that I I I
wanted to I want to go somewhere Monday
Tuesday Wednesday where I don't need
pressure I don't have that at the comedy
store if I had a place right now tonight
that we could go to 11:00 i' be I would
love to do it right now I'd be there
even if there was eight people I would
be there the same thing goes for Tuesday
the same thing goes for Wednesday you
know I would be there in a heartbeat
but it's not the way things turn out you
know this week I got to shoot this thing
this TV show so I'm pretty
congratulations on that yeah Hey listen
man this is 20 years of I don't get work
like I used to let me give some shout
outs Angel adoro Jeff Collins David
tamamo Ben austo Anthony
sabido Matt hire I'll see you in
Milwaukee [__] Chris tent and my
man Garnet on Chuck this guy was here
last week love Garnet he's great from
Canada dude he's a bad dude Garnett is
over there hanging himself right now
he's thinking of disconnecting his
internet he just wants to move to LA and
hang out with the boys that's all he
wants to do I can't get mad at him for
how many years have you been here for
now Steve September will be 17 and what
do you think did you sacrifice a lot for
your
country I don't know if I could do it
over again is the truth I really don't
know if I had to if I had to I don't
know if I was yeah I sacrificed enough I
don't know if I could do it again but
I'm very
grateful for all of the uh the
opportunities I've had because of the
sacrifices when I think about going like
I've been to Afghanistan on the front
lines making people laugh I've been
bedside at Children's hospital with kids
through the worst things life can just
comedy brought me all those great
experiences so for that I'm
grateful it's funny when you watch
crashing like like I I was in New York
for nine
months and when I watch Pete Holmes
there's a part where the girl says to
him you know so how do you how you
making a living he goes I'm not yeah I'm
just having the best time in my life and
I could look at both you
guys and think about that time in my
life and how much fun I was having being
broke stealing change from cars in the
service department I'm selling cars at
and it was a [__] Journey every day I
would have to get up at 6:00 to take the
7:00 bus cuz my friend's dad drove that
bus and he would let me on for free
great you know $2.50 I would get
$250 with that $2 I like a juice and a
butter roll right but it's hard to
believe that I would say I would get up
2 hours earlier just to be able to eat
to eat a buted roll and [__] uh juice
a freshly squeezed orange juice it's
insane it's [__]
crazy and I do it again Steve Simone I
would do it again I just don't know if I
could I think back to those like fat
James years Stevie Z remember him Stevie
kicking me out of the apartment if you
and Paul got into a big fight
tonight and you felt bad and you gave a
half the money in your
account which you're looking at me you
rather i' have to feel with I don't know
what I do you probably hiry yourself
before you give somebody money that's
when you stick a knife in your stomach
and cut yourself sideways God forbid I
already know what anyway knife I'd use
I'm just saying to you you know what if
you married Paula and right you had a
child and you got to an argument with
her because you went on the road with us
and stayed out too long and she took the
kid to your mothers and she took half of
your account and now she going to take
your credit cards Max them
out I didn't smell nothing now she Maxes
him out and now you're a depressed guy
would you go for what you dreamed of a
long time ago or would you continue
doing what you were doing
Le I mean when you have nothing to lose
that's when you go for it in your life
yeah you
know on I
mean do you mean I would I keep doing
this or would I go back to editing no no
no no no
like I'm talking about like in Pete
Holmes situation that show crashing
right him and his wife break up he gets
into Comedy full steam ahead you know
he's sleeping I mean when I tell you the
story sometimes you look at me like with
three eyes like getting to Michigan
early and having to sleep in your car in
a car and to me it was so liberating
yeah to get out of the car in the
morning and stretch out in the sunlight
and walk into a place with six bucks and
hope you get
breakfast just hope you get breakfast
and hope I came on open at 10 so you
could bring back a pair of car mats and
get $26 so you can eat a Subway veggie
and cheese and get $10 worth of weed
that's what I'm talking about the rent
on it's the it's the four third it's the
third of the month yeah you're going to
pay the rent on the fifth as far as maze
rently it's the farthest thing from your
mind you're not even thinking about it
right your car is parked over at Steve
Simone's garage because you're two
months late with the payment and you
can't leave it on the street because you
know they're hunting for it do you know
what that lifestyle is like in a way no
oh and then to top it off you're going
to close an open mic that's only going
to have eight people and you're going to
close the show at
12:45 but at 11:00 the room empties out
it's so you have no idea the frustration
and the [__] horror I lived I would
drive a limo and sign up and Y old
triple in a 10 and they would go come
back at
2:30 like definitely two and and then
you come back at 2:30 and they're
like maybe another hour and you're like
oh my God
and I got a Coke Rock in my pocket and
it's burning a hole in that [__]
and all I want to do is crack this to
two stupid jokes I wrote from the Judy
cter workbook so I could go home and
blast off to Colombia Ville you know you
have no [__] idea Le I was paying
Grandma I was sending child support
trying to snort
coke trying to [__] buy
clothes and I tell you what guys here's
the sad thing I can't lie of you guys I
was making
money when I think about those busted
times in ' 93 I was paying 365 a month
for child support I was probably paying
300 a month
rent everything else was me eating up
and my cocaine habit wow those are the
two nuts I had I buy groceries for the
house once a week maybe 60 bucks so my
nut was 1,800 I was making 800 a week
delivering sandwiches my friend wow from
10 to [__] 230 at hashway and then
I'd go into the City and do whatever the
[__] else I had to do I was making
$3,200 base and I was still struggling
how [__] crazy is
that because I was buying 20 bucks of
weed a day yep and $35 of cocaine every
day wow add that up 55 time 30 that's a
lot of [__] money
dog wow once in a while would buy a p
sneakers once in a while buy two pair of
P I worked in the city so I would walk
past those outlets and just buy two pair
of pants for 15 bucks [__] it I'd buy a
sixpack of white socks good to go why
buy underwear who needs them it's an
necessity you don't need that $5 I can
use it for something else $650
$1600 or 16,000
16,600 a month mon was my drug habit
five times your rent and that's without
my [__] tolls and food I ate when I
went to drugs that's that's crazy that
was my struggle doing drugs and
struggling open mics but you know what I
do it all over again that roommate I had
till this day I haven't written anything
about those days and those are some of
the best I was living in such pain then
cuz I had lost my daughter I knew I was
going a loser I thought at this time I
was going to go back to Boulder and be a
father and everything would be forgiven
yeah but that was just a delusional mind
[__] but at the time I lived at Georgie
I just went to chance dragging in with
him on Thursday and every time I look at
him I think about those nine months and
how me and George have been friends for
40 years but with two different animals
now mhm I love them dearly because of
three or four different time periods of
my life he plugged the hole like a
brother that's great I mean he plugged
the [__] hole but that heroin those
nine months of heroin wore some of the
funny EST times I ever saw in my life
and it was watching somebody else
deteriorate but he didn't care about
himself so I would just torment him I
would torment him and he would torment
me too don't get me wrong but every
night I knew he want to shoot up I knew
he had a certain look on his face he'd
be dying to shoot up but it was me him
and his grandmother and his grandmother
knew he was a filth a filthy junkie so
she would watch him like a [__] Hawk
at night and he would play L it out like
everything was cool and as I mean dog
Grandma's door wouldn't
go and he was already dodging to the
bathroom to shoot heroin wow and I'd
give him like five
minutes and then I tiptoe and they had a
gang in the hallway and I'd hit the gang
and go back to bed and she' come out
what the [__] was that and then she'd
look in the room and go where's George
like I don't know and she'd run to the
bathroom and bang on the door George I
know what you're doing in there and he'd
be shooting up and [__] and then he come
back and go you couldn't talk to F and
I'd say like I don't know what happened
she went right to the door I would
torment him dog I would torment them
every [__] night how did he get over
it he went to jail he went to jail and
he chose he told the judge just throw me
in jail cuz I'm never going to get clean
he had already gone to 20 rehabs
and but it was those nine months with
him had just gone through a divorce I
was going to war with these
people and I went back home and and I
actually went back home like it was the
first time I lived at home in 8 years
but I needed to go home I needed to walk
those streets again yeah I needed to
remember who the [__] I was and if I was
going to get into comedy I really needed
to remember who I was you know that's a
good point so it was uh but I look at
George now and I laugh because I think
of I still remember him accusing me of
robbing his bus pass and me going George
I ride the bus for free every [__]
day why would I Rob your bus P because I
know you did it you you know what he
used to do in those days he he moved
rocks at the park two days a week three
hours he would move rocks with a thing
and they give him $140 a week in a bus
pass because he was a junkie he was on a
junkie program in Cliffside Park and
that's what you do like get a junkie out
of the house program so you go down to
the park you sweep a little bit for 3
hours and they give you a buck 40 in the
methodone card and a bus card and a
syringe I'm not kidding wow he had this
program down two days a week I think it
was six hours a day
and the government gives you a little
money it's called the Momo program or
something I'm program oh yeah yeah now
today he's doing well he has his own
he's Partners on a frame company and he
raises his daughter and he loses Grand
Grandma's still alive I was over the
other night George lie MC Grandma racist
racist as
[__] she's telling me Fidel died in
California she's 91 Now dog and she she
tells
105 she's like I'm 105 Grandma you're
[__] 91 pretty interesting [__] like
what this journey you're right the
sacrifice was really worth the journey
it was the journey absolutely and would
I do it again [__] yeah yeah [__] yeah I
would do this all over again the
suffering was definitely worth it the
only thing I wouldn't do again is do
with an addiction right I wouldn't do it
with an addiction that's the only thing
I suggest but I suggest the struggle and
the [__] the struggle is what I think
it gave me just more compassion for
people you know what I mean like the
more I suffered the less I wanted to see
anybody else suffer or when they were
going through it I could see it you know
like even the young Comics up at the
store like tonight I'm going to go up
there and I'm just going to listen you
know sometimes you show up and listen
you know what I mean that's the best
that's the
best sit in the back and watch The
Comedians go and then they come Lear you
learn a ton you learn a ton watching
people I just I loved it I loved when I
lived in Hollywood and I get a spot like
at 11:30 and you go at 9:30 smoke a
little dope and just sit in the back
when it used to be empty I'd sit all the
way in the back with a baseball hat on
so nobody would know me I wasn't
stealing jokes I was I was just watching
and learning yeah that's it you you can
learn from anybody in comedy you can
learn from an open micer you can learn
from a feature act you can learn from a
headline that's a great thing about
comedy every time I watch Comedy close
enough three four days it could be
[__] Tommy Easter y it could be Steve
Simone it could be Joe Rogan it could be
B rer I learned something I think that
was part of mit's
Genius always funny tremendous
tremendous come on there's the
Philadelphia report what the [__] but I
was saying I like to go up there and
just be there for the other Comics
listen to what they're going through you
know the kids in the struggle see what I
could do to help out my new things I
feed them I either make pizzas or ziti
or something
cuz bringing food up to The Comedy Store
it's like bringing food to a home I tell
you something I have the same compassion
at The Comedy Store I look at those guys
and I give them the utmost respect
they're the new Marines yes I'm that fat
old [__] with the crew cut that comes
around and says you guys don't know
nothing I was here when Eddie Griffin
was doing four hours and then dice would
follow and do two hours you know I feel
like that guy I feel like the old guy in
Full Metal Jacket and I just annoy Lee
and all the other 28y olds that's
everybody loves you that's him that's
I'm full metal jacket and that's Lee
this ends with lee pulling a gun on me
shooting me then shooting himself in the
bathroom what was his name what was that
Lun private pile yeah private pile what
is in your lunchbox a jelly donut that
is one of the funniest scenes in movie
history I I when he goes when he goes go
po what's his what do you call him go
see if they got donut scene and Full
Metal Jacket that's
that Vincent denafo that's vincenta that
turn he makes in that no no no no he's
he listen that guy every time people
like what do you think do you want to
hire F off remember Full Metal Jacket
you got a point so good yeah hire you
remember that
scely uh that's you I believe so that's
you when he finds a donut somehow I
don't think Som I don't think this is
very complimentary but what the [__] is
this that is there are two scenes in
there that till this day dog I still
fall off the couch when he ask when he
says
Jesus you know Mary Jesus and Joseph and
he starts smacking them and beating them
up that is one of the funniest scenes
I'm going to go back and watch that and
above the law tonight the good thing
about these two movies is you don't have
to watch the whole movie with this [__]
you just have to watch I remember this
movie freaking me out a little bit he
shoots himself yeah and after that the
movie blows once the hooker says Me So
Horny you're like okay I've had
enough really look at that face it is
like two different movies but two
different put the jelly
donut is this it yeah yeah that's it
that's Lee look
what I'm that I'm the old guy in that's
Le go ahead put that on watch
this to
[Music]
jam pop that
blister
Jesus H
Christ private pile why is your Foot
Locker Unlocked sir I don't know sir
private pile if there is one thing in
this world that I hate it is an unlocked
Foot Locker you know that don't you sir
yes sir if it wasn't for [__] like
you there wouldn't be any th in this
world would there sir no sir get
him this is this right here right here
this is the best ever let's just see if
there's anything
missing holy
Jes what is that what the [__] is
that what is that private pile sir jelly
donut sir a jelly donut sir yes sir how
did it get here sir I took it from the
mess hall sir is CH allowed in the
barracks private pie sir no sir are you
allowed to eat jelly donuts private pie
sir no sir sir and why not private pile
sir because I'm too heavy sir because
you are a disgusting B body private pile
sir yes sir then why did you hide a
jelly donut in your
foot because I was hungry sir because
you were
hungry private pile has Dishonored
himself and honored The
Paton I have tried to help him but I
have failed I have failed because you
have not helped me that's how I feel you
people have not given private P the
proper
motivation Jesus so from now on whenever
private pile [__] up I will not punish
him I will punish all of you and the way
I see it ladies you owe me for one jelly
donut now get on your
faces open your mouth they're paying for
it you eat
it excise out this cold blooded
[__] I put the first pile
s you could stop this I don't need time
now that guy was the real deal right
click just back to and see if we see it
on that scroll jelly dut scene [__]
hilarious right there right there that
one that one do you believe in the
Virgin Mary that's a good one
too that's this is [__] hysterical
this part right
here drop your [__] and grab your sock
you imagine that's me waking you up at 4
in the morning
torturing I can live for this [__] call
be the
best private Cowboy private Joker sir
yes sir sir yes sir as soon as you
finish your bunks I want you two turds
to clean the head sir I want that head
so sanitary and squared away that the
Virgin Mary herself would be proud to go
in there and take a dunp sir yes sir I
have a joker do you believe in the
Virgin Mary sir no
sir I have a jokeer I don't believe I
hurt you correct sir the private said no
sir sir why you little maggot you make
me want to BM
it
backy this is the barbecue conversation
we had you do love the Virgin Mary Don't
You negative sir private Joker are you
trying to offend me sir negative sir sir
the private believes that any answer he
gives will be wrong and the senior drill
instructor will beat him harder if he
reverses himself sir who's your squad
leader scumbag the private Squad leaders
private snowball sir private
snowball sir private snowb Your da sir
private snowball you're fired private
Joker promoted to squad leader sir sir
disappears
scumbag on the
pile priv P sir private pile from now on
private Joker is your new squad leader
and you will bunk with him he'll teach
you everything he'll teach you how to
pee sir yes sir private Joker is silly
and he's ignorant but he's got guts and
guts is enough now you ladies carry on
sir I
sir silly and ignorant but he got guts
[__] hilarious this [__] so good this
is this is this is another movie that
came
out7 un [__] believe I can't wait for
they make this
over all right Rambo you can take this
off now now you scaring me to death you
got these soldiers and [__] I don't know
if the platoon's
coming
the what else buddy that's it that's all
you got for me today you C up you made
pizzas where you going with you so you
going to Bard me July 29th where you
going before that any other things you
got going on I got the yo thing uh
hopefully starting back on AR's TV show
and then I do if I could give a shout
out to the nonprofit I'm doing there's a
a family with a very sick little boy
that we're trying to help and uh all the
money we rais is just for right
now it's just going to go to this family
way to create as many good memories with
their kid as they can while they can so
um if you want to make a donation and
help my little buddy stepen out you can
just go to regular her.org even if you
got a couple bucks it'll be appreciated
and uh we're just trying to put some joy
into this family's life that's it wow
the time still yeah it's very sad
diagnosis yeah any but there could be a
miracle you know there's uh there's some
hope out there so it's great you just
pray and that's it there's always a
[__] miracle man you know that's
we're still here yep we're still here in
this [__] game so yeah the main key
of this podcast tonight was just if you
really think you're getting places see
how much you really
sacrifice you know I found it out like I
said Saturday night when I I would have
loved to stay with those guys and done a
thousand things and seen
niak but it's so important to who I was
then and now when I started making
progress was when I beat myself up yeah
and you know what want to make
progress sometimes you have to piss off
the people around you because people
don't understand when you do things for
yourself they really don't people do not
want to comprehend when you look at
somebody and go I'm not doing that I got
to do this for myself yeah I don't care
what you're thinking I don't care what
you want to do whatever you want to do
is fine but this is what I'm doing from
now on at this time period you know and
I learned that from Mitch Hedberg you
know all the greats sacrifice something
yeah you know and that's
I don't think people don't understand
how much sacrifice goes into this I
don't understand how much even Lee Lee's
close to his mother Lee's sacrificing
himself right now Lee has to wake up
every 16 days cuz I know him and he
evaluate you know he's a nerdy [__] he
gets high and he goes into his head and
he's I know him I know that he ask
himself what the [__] he's doing out
here because that's his cut that's the
cut he comes from yeah but I want lead
to know that every morning when he wakes
up part of that sacrifice is two
things you start out with a goal every
day and you have to attain that goal for
the sacrifice not to be a
waste if not the sacrifice is a waste
back up your bags and go home to your
mother and your family in Florida you
get a part-time job tell people you're a
comedian maybe you pick up a house MC
job nobody really needs this yeah but to
not feel that your love your is in vain
you have to get up every morning and go
okay two things have to happen number
one if I do this somebody's got to pay
me to do this mhm like I'm not F you
have to put a value upon yourself it's
true and that's very hard for people to
imagine for listen I'm an electrician
you're paying me 850 an hour blah blah
blah blah you know you also have to
justify that don't come to me and go
well I worked 42 hours last week yeah
but you were the first one to go both
nights somebody wants to be an
electrician is the first one here and
the last one to to go and doesn't
complain about he has to go to the
movies or doesn't complain about the
superhero movies coming out tonight he's
been waiting they don't care about that
you want to own this company one day
this is what needs to be done yeah
everything else gets torn apart you know
I bust Le's balls about Paul and him
staying home at night I can't tell him
until one day he comes to me and goes
dog why didn't you punch me in the
[__] mouth two years ago I threw away
two years of my life 10 hours a week
watching stupid TV shows I will say what
the old get the more valuable my time
yeah oh when you're 28 you don't have
think about it wait a second and that's
when I try to tell anybody who's under
[__] 30 here put a value on your time
yes if you don't do it
now it's it's going to take too long it
took me till I was 44 I'm a loser
compared to you guys you guys got this
in front of you you make sure that every
day counts yes you know in my world the
day was complete if I got a half Grand a
Coke but guess what I always got that
half Grand I always got it my goal was
to go out in the daytime once I hit the
comedy store I get 10 from you 10 from
Lee 10 from this guy I got my 40 yeah I
get a check from the store on Friday and
I'll pay them all back and then we'll
move on with this in my world it was
that and to do a set that justified my
existence who the [__] I was trying to
be and that's what I've been telling Lee
and anybody else I I I like everybody to
have a relationship and everything but
there Comes a Day you sit the woman down
and go
listen you want to go here you want to
go there we need to buy a house yeah you
want to get a dog we need to do this
this just don't come exactly this just
don't come I wish I could walk into uh
7-Eleven and give the Hindu $3 and he
gives me the $150 million ticket I wish
it was like that yeah and I get the one
payment and buy two properties and go to
China go to Taiwan get my dick sucked
eat some [__] Lobster taals and come
back and tell my wife I love it but
that's not the case that's not America
that's not that's a few people who get
lucky you have to really evaluate this
you know when I was married I thought it
was the 40 hour plan too until I hated
my wife then I got more hours to to
compliment it and then when she left I
was like life is seven days a week as
much as you don't want it to be yep you
know I'm going to the UFC this week I'm
doing Buffalo you think I'm going to sit
at the [__] UFC and wants the fight
not really I'm on that plane at 6:00
a.m. Saturday more I don't give a [__]
about no fight y if it's between this or
me riding or look at look at if I would
have stayed in nyak I would have never
booked this role right I wouldn't have
prepared myself I wouldn't have been
prepared these are the little sacrifices
you have to make I would want I didn't
put flowers on my mother's grave this
time I thought about postponing my trip
till Monday then I got that audition y
my mother's been dead for 30 years she
could wait till November for flowers or
you never know I might go back in I got
to go back in July to the B God I might
go up that Sunday that Sunday and put
flowers I have a thousand options right
and I honestly believe you you using
your talent to its fullest capabilities
preparing for that audition that's the
best kind of flowers you can give your
mother you know what I mean a life well-
lived a life filled with joy that's the
best thing you can do for all the people
that made sacrifices for you for you
yeah is is to find the joy in
living that's what I think about when I
miss my parents I go why did my dad work
two three jobs why were they always
there because they wanted me to be the
best version of me and this sucks that
I'm not with them right now this you're
making it work you're out of here
absolutely it's not like you're waiting
for an envelope you're have to [__]
Open Mic waiting for an envelope right
you've worked all the I remember when
you were struggling with this guy and
this guy now you got the apartment you
got the car things happen y listen it
took you 12 years or whatever justes a
[__] 15 years to even start making a
listen you going to you going to be
doing something you didn't want to do
that's the that's another great piece of
piece of advice the time's going to go
by Jesus Christ it's going to go by
sitting in a cubicle doing what you
don't want to do or it's going to go by
while you're going towards your dream
and you know what thank God thank God
thank God I I put the time in towards my
dream cuz doing what you don't want to
do you might as well throw yourself in
jail yep that's jail and you don't know
what that's like to you about in your
30s and you gotten yourself in a
position you're like how did I get
myself in this position yeah this is
when I wanted to do all the things I
really wanted to do now I can't do them
I remember when I was 22 there were kids
I was doing a corporate job and kids
were talking 22 they were 22 and they
were talking about what they were going
to do when they retired I go what you're
talking about 45 years from now you
don't know unless Fu crystal ball
goodbye what if that guy runs the red
light with that truck what are you
thinking about 45 years
exactly so grateful for all the
experiences I've had I knew what I could
do and I knew what I didn't want to do
yes you know and that was a good point
that was the good thing I'm happy you
came on today Steve great way to start
off a month Lee say's in that place
where he needs to be l
don't forget you bad [__] I'm
at Levity Live in Oxnard for 420 Leo
will be there eating 15 stars that night
with his father and then on the 27th I'm
in the Tumblr Brewing house up there in
[__] Bakersfield having a good time
so yeah I'm in the Valley the next month
uh after this week I'm in Buffalo number
one always hello tushi.com the Beday are
back listen I've since I was a kid I'm
one of those people that sits there and
when somebody walks by with a big ass I
say to myself
imagine what that ass must smell like
and that's where B comes in where's the
siren Le where's the siren you know what
I'm saying that's the siren
hellotushy.com is a is a portable bedet
you can install yourself in your
bathroom okay no expensive pipings no
Plumbing no nothing available it all
there you go that's when you know it's a
good [__] when your asshol stinks
that's the song that plays and you go to
your Beday and boom it keeps your ass
clean it keeps your nuts that clean but
in all honesty it's so much healthier
especially when you're sitting on your
butt all day this is a good way to avoid
hemorrhoids and crotch rot and
everything else that comes you ever you
scratch your ass midday you know how bad
it [__] smells everybody at home
scratches their ass from time to time
and smells their fingers and says what
the [__] did I eat Tuesday but no more
no more not with hellotushy.com you also
have a 60-day money back guarantee okay
Lee tell them about hello tushi and how
it change your life oh it it it starts
my day and ends my day every day it's
amazing it's I it's you do the hot water
the you I have the cold I only have the
cold and I I was worried about it a
little bit it it it's not that cold and
it feels great and hey black [__] cold
water there's no differences go to
hellotushy.com right now take a look at
what they have take a look at the bedet
tell me you wouldn't want a bedet for
your house you understand me go to
hellotushy.com and press in church and
get 10% off your order there's nothing
like hello tushi why have a stinky
[__] vaginal hole why have a stinky
ass hole why have a stinky pee hole when
you go to hellotushy.com and get 10% off
the b day right now go to hellotushy.com
your mother she her [__] stinks she's
68 years old nobody needs up a day more
than your rotten mother's [__] snatch
go to hellotushy.com right now and
Father's Day is coming that dirty old
[__] old man the other day I
scratched my balls and I smelt old man
balls I got right on that [__] bedet
and I [__] Irish Spring those nuts
with that cold water and I listen once
you hit the certain age you get stinky
old men balls go to hellotushy.com right
now ni church that's right at Preston
church and get 10% off to your house all
right delivered to your house why [__]
around around what's your [__] deal
we're not trying to insult you that's
the name of the new standup comedy show
on seeso Big J ocasin what's your
[__] deal features Big J plus other
Big Time comics insulting a a room full
of people in a unique standup comedy
show that's all crowd work so we may not
be trying to insult you but they
definitely are CEO is where it's at you
understand me you got my special on
there you got Nick depalo special on
there you got I mean you got Doug Stan
hope Doug stanh hope you got original
programming this is the way to go fim
anir who fim Amir I mean it's so many
Lorie Kil Martin I mean the party never
stops last year a comedy Arena was born
where standups roam looking to slay
audiences they call that Arena ciso
where no laugh is spared and no
punchline is left behind this month big
J enson and dozens of other headlining
Comics join the fry in season two of big
J oasin but on top of that do you like
to laugh chuckle shortle cuckle guffle
Snicker then ceso is for you with ceso
you get unlimited access to ceso
Original Series next day late night
hilarious standup specials and binge
worthy Classics including 42 that's
right that's 42 seasons of Saturday
Night Live and the entire Monty Python
collection The IT Crowd and more with
seeso you get binge worthy Classics
British C comic comedy and original
series like Harmon Quest and bajillion
dollar properties not to mention the
entire SNL Library ceso bring stand up
right to your living room with exclusive
content from today's best comedians and
on demand and listen to this one
commercial free sign up now to catch
brand new standup specials from Nick
myself fah Amir big J okas right now do
me a favor just go to seo.com right now
and sign up one month free with promo
code Joey at checkout ready for a punch
line after to that ceso is just $3.99 a
month no joke $3.99 a month for all the
comedy you want anytime anywhere at free
you can access ceso content from
anywhere at any time using iOS Android
Roku Apple TV Amazon Fire TV Windows
Xbox and watch your favorite set from
comedians like Louis CK Amy Schumer and
hanal bars this is let's
if you don't have ceso shoot yourself
you [__] go to seo.com right now sign up
for one free one month free with promo
code Joey and checkout again that's
seo.com spelled
seo.com promo code Joey and get one
month free right now go over there
seo.com promo code Joey I want to thank
on it I want to thank ciso and I want to
thank my main [__] over there
at hellotushy.com keep keeping Mufflers
clean that's the motto for
2017 I want to thank my man Steve Simone
and is also my co- captain of this
journey my favorite Jewish person in the
world Lisa at we'll be back Wednesday
for you no [__] games I love you
[__] stay black and have a great
night I want to thank Steve again don't
forget to support his foundation what's
the name of it regular her.org regular
her.org $5 $5
$5 get it together all right you could
save a kid's life you can make their
[__] dream come true they go to
Disneyland he takes some roller skate
and he buys him helmets he makes pizza
you know the [__] deal go to the hero
what is it regular hero regular hero.com
all right I love you [__] stay
black Uncle Joey loves you I'll see you
[__] 420 Oxnard
levity hit it
Lee CR was the funniest
thing
[Music]
so so you think you could
tell Heaven from
Hell blue skies from
pain can you tell a green
field from a cold steel rain
[Music]
a smile from a
veil do you think you can
tell did they get you to
Train Your Heroes for
G hot ashes for
trees hot air for a cool
breeze cold comfort for
change
did you
exchange I walk on part in the wall for
a lead roll in a
[Music]
cage
how I wish how I wish you were
here we're just two lost soul sing in a
fish
bow year after
year running over the same old
ground what have we
found the same old
fear wish you were
[Music]
here
d
[Music]
do
w